Miguel conception own you reviewed it
for gamespot Miguel you do a lot of
freelance work for us or some you're
working from the office a lot lately
you're working on another review for us
right now which can't completely take
call duty you can't give an opinion but
you're working on the review for us um
you gave battle if you wanted nine out
of ten you thought this game was superb
as a lot of us do so let's talk about
broad strokes why is this game like good
well I found that both the single player
and the multiplayer were both were both
excellent um any kind of misgivings I
had was or any thing that I thought were
blemishes was actually just coming down
to the UI especially the multiplayer
something like not being able to exit
the multiplayer mode in between matches
was really surprising oh right yeah you
noticed it was actually easier you
actually have to wait for the next match
to start before he can actually get into
the pause menu okay um and it came to
the point where it was easy it was
probably easier for me to just like exit
out of the game and then relaunch it in
order to get back into the main menu
dances like those kind of like quality
of life things they could hopefully
improve down the road like right stuff
and whatnot uh yeah but do you think of
the world war one setting you think it
kind of lends itself well to this kind
of game yeah I thought it was almost
long overdue you know it was always
whenever you see like a feature about
where should this shooter franchise go
world war one is always like throwing is
sort of like a novelty suggestion or an
afterthought and light now at EA and
dice I thought they can just like jump
straight into and like make it this
full-on triple-a production and I just
thought they did a great job on it to
the point that you could really see like
we're working gold like a possible
sequel or DLCs obviously when you have
like this four year long conflict
there's so many battles that you can
cover especially when even like the
campaign covers mostly Wars from like
the last two years I mean battles from
the last two years of the war there were
obviously many other conflicts in the in
the initial stages yeah especially with
this sort of the seesaw of the the
Germans and the French on the Western
Front that pretty much took up like the
first like not six months yeah
I do want to talk about the progressions
rob you and I had like how many
battlepacks saved up for the stream we
did today six when we open it up yeah so
the battle packs are kind of like what
like overwatch does with Luke rates
called duties doing with its supply
drops i think they're called a lot of
games do that now it's that randomized
items that like I think mass effect 3 I
remember was the first one I remember on
consoles kind of introducing that random
loot box weird segue for that but I'm
kind of interested in how the
progression feels for this like are you
like unlocking new like these World War
1 weapons pretty often these new skins
are like how does the progression feel
overall cuz call duty that's like the
big draw from use the progression well
it's multi-layered not surprisingly the
currency that you earn to buy new
weapons is these war bonds that you get
not through completing matches but
through leveling up so I want to make
that distinction okay there's also these
metals that sort of work like challenges
I mean in the classic sense of
challenges except in order for it
incentivizes you to come back weekly
because these challenges are essentially
temporary and you also have to make sure
that you equip these metals so you
actually get uh you can actually like I
guess for lack of better word grow these
channel Ivan grow these metals yeah I
really appreciate how you can just mold
your your your your your arsenal based
on what you prefer because they it just
has such a wide spectrum of old-school
weapons and it will take like even like
the most hardcore player like weeks to
possibly get like me in the full
collection so I remember I was playing
as a support class earlier and I know
since the betas they in the Alpha they
introduced the mortar I don't believe
that was there during the for release so
I've been idling so I and I like swap
out the the other possible items there
for the mortar all the times I really
like that kind of makes the support
class kind of literally two more support
your kind of like bombarding these areas
trying to clear out these strongholds
and I was telling rob earlier on the
episode that we I like battlefield
because there's those moments where like
you have to be kind of patient to be
good at battlefield right it's like
about placement on the it's literally
about placement the battlefield
and it's kind of about putting yourself
in the right situation to help whether
you're killing somebody or not or you
just laying down suppressing fire or
you're kind of going this flank
admission like to round to just get this
stronghold no one's paying attention to
does this feel like a kind of return to
form for the battlefield series in a lot
of ways cuz I know like I think for
there's a lot of server issues when like
when was a for launched and I'm just
like hardly I was kind of like Scott was
saying earlier still that like a lot of
it was more like close quarters stuff
like kind of trying to combat these
other modern military shooters but the
bow fee once seemed like kind of a
return to tradition for the Battlefield
franchise I'd say so especially when as
a contrast the the amount of work in
imagination they put into the maps it
just seems like actual maps at you
actual locations you could actually
visit in real life and I say contrast
because so many damn maps so many of the
maps from hardline feel or what seemed
like so symmetrical by comparison
obviously to be good at any kind of like
map in any multiplayer shooter it just
really comes down to just memorizing the
layout because any given man I think one
of my favorite maps is one in this
French farm that shares a shares like a
couple towns and half of the buildings
are in ruins and you know you're going
to have your share of of camping spots
and just areas where we can snipe well
in all I really appreciate the maps
because it also led to me playing
outside my comfort zone trying out
classes i usually don't don't play with
right um I thought it was really like
sniper friendly and at least before the
wide release my at home cable connection
with a wireless router I was able to
pull off sniper kills without any kind
of lag or any issues and I was very
pleased with that yeah because then
there's like that analog feel all these
weapons or older weapons there's that
yeah the lead targets there's bullet
drop like especially like I'm sniper
rifle shooting in long distances but
just reloading oh yeah you have to
reload like not even just the clip Ohio
the zoo Bowl
yeah I mean for artillery things pieces
to yeah yeah definitely it's I don't
know there's definitely more it's
battlefield so there's more weight to
the weapons here than call of duty feels
like you're just like pointing this wing
this like toy gun at people but there's
more weight to them it's a little bit
harder like a lot of times I'll see a
guy across a field and i'll be using the
trench submachine gun and I'll be like I
can't make this shot by the time I hit
him once and do like 10 damage to him
he's gonna have killed me with whatever
he's using and I actually pick my shots
more consistently I'm like paying more
attention to the situation than I would
in like a lot of other like twitchy kind
of shooters but there's also the thing
that you said that these don't feel like
arenas to me these feel like actual you
feel like real places that people just
happen to be like playing a game on I
don't know and it does feel a lot more
like they're these kind of uh there's
this like natural feel to them like
organic I guess would be the true I mean
when you play something like conquest
sometimes you think this side is
naturally the other team's side but that
never really happens because as always
it keeps evolving like a team that can
dominate one side of the map by they on
the match-day and up dominating the
other side and you guys like organically
just switch areas one thing I always
loved about these battlefield maps
because it really caters to teamwork I
mean obviously you could you could be
like a lone wolf or a little bit but in
you probably won't be that much of a you
won't really contribute much at the
grant in the grand scheme of things yeah
definitely and it's kind of like some of
the maps play out is like these
individual skirmishes they're playing on
different capture points or like houses
or farms like you said others kind of
like Sinai desert I always found that it
was kind of like these these outlying
battles that are playing into the
central and the town it's kind of like
cool and then there's one along the
coast i forget the name of it with the
dread-nots in the castle and that's the
one where it's fao fortress fortress yes
and that's the one where it's kind of
you know like until the Dreadnought
comes in everybody's kind of attacking
the castle and the castles that
stronghold that's kind of tough to take
but then there's the one up on the hill
you can take I know it's just kind of
thinking back on the stories that come
out of these matches like oh like I
couldn't take that castle but then I'll
sudden I came in the dread-nots start
bombarding it kill everybody people came
in the back and took it then I capsizing
the ship which you this really happened
to me I got you smokes oh yeah it's it's
kind of nice too because it was a little
worrisome when like you know they
introduced the behemoth blimp yeah oh my
god this thing is just gonna wreck
shop however the balancing of it seems
to be pretty safe like you know if it is
a landslide match and it's 20 minutes
long and you're just you know having not
these behemoths you kind of know halfway
through that your team's gonna lose sure
but now it's like okay even if we are
winning we have to worry about a tank
and that that is your automatic sense of
drive for teamwork is like we have to
take out that I'm sorry train we have to
take out the train or the whatever
behemoth it is in order to like ensure
that we will win and the the matches
have been so tight like I 11 as a train
artillery conductor like we want buy
three tickets uh it was exhilarating
ledge essentially is three seconds for
those who haven't played right right and
that's it's cool and the Bohemians come
in how they switch like your role like
if you're a plane before the behemoth
before like an airship comes in you're
doing strafing runs your bombing tanks
your dog fighting with other planes your
maybe like again strafing runs are
bombing like a capture point to help
your foot soldiers get in there the
airship comes along it's pretty much
like you're one of the first lines of
defense to take out the gondolas
underneath it they have all the machine
guns and dropping bombs and whatnot and
that's one thing i like how these
matches can like you said this scenario
switches so fast like you could be a
scout and you're like a me across this
field trying to take out people that are
trying to cross it to get the capture
point you want to his house next door
just becomes close quarters battles and
you are having a tough time with just
your sidearm against shotguns um i do
want to talk quickly about the campaign
because that was like one thing that
nobody really played before you came out
there's no beta or alpha from what i
understand but what did you think the
campaign like as far as again making use
of the war war one setting or just
overall quality like how fun was it well
it's presented in this entao anthology
format where it almost comes off where
the it seems like they're all these um
it could have each segment could have
been written by a different writer right
each one has their own tone each main
character kind of has their own
personality and motivations overall it
just really it it was thoughtful and
heartfelt and it really is a contrast
with the previous battle field campaigns
where by comparison it actually really
accentuates how the prior campaigns
especially with battlefield 3 and 4 how
those were just like these persistent
powder kegs where each each chapter felt
like it had something to prove and
always had to felt some obligation to
keep like your your pulse up this one
that's you know just like this ebb and
flow with you know like say we like the
this tank mission the camaraderie with
that that you quickly gained from you
know meeting all these strangers in this
tank there's really heartfelt one in
where this a veteran it looks like he's
he's like seven years old and it's like
the 1950s and he's reflecting on his
time when he was protecting his twin
brother in this mission in in the Alps
yeah yeah no it's I mean like I'm
excited to play it because for all
intents purposes seems like it's making
use of the world war one setting more
than maybe the multiplayer in some
respects as far as a storytelling goes
and that is the appeal to me because of
the heart that appears to be there I
mean I will also say that i love that
many of the settings aren't just reusing
assets from the the multiplayer map I
mean some games can get away with that
but I really I really thought that the
that art team really did a great job in
just really mixing things up and there
was one particular map that actually
looked like some 19th century painting
with just these really really yellow and
orange like afternoons I don't want to
spoil deciding because sometimes just
even seeing these levels for the first
time is it night is a pleasant surprise
sure yeah well anyway that is
battlefield one Miguel conceptional and
thanks so much for coming on to talk
about it i'll give it a nine out of 10
your review is up video review as well
as written on gamespot i think it's
still promo to top the page so you can
go read that right now if you're
interested in battlefield one and
checking it out but let us know what you
think about the game the comments below
once you get to play it